This is not 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Over five years ago, I started doing another podcast about constitutional law. Trump had started serving his term and Twitter and various places where above with people discussing the constitutionality of everything he did. Obscure sections like the emoluments clause were being discussed for the first time in my lifetime anyway. So I asked the neighbor of mine who is a law school professor and very funny on Twitter named Zalizbiccio to teach me constitutional law using Trump tweets and you know various things happening in the news. We call the show what Trump can teach us about Khan Law.
这不是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。五年多前，我开始制作另一档关于宪法的播客。当时特朗普刚开始他的任期，推特和各种平台上到处都是人们在讨论他所做一切的合宪性。像“薪酬条款”（emoluments clause）这样晦涩难懂的章节，至少在我有生之年是第一次被讨论。所以我请了我的邻居——一位法学院教授，在推特上非常风趣，名叫伊丽莎白·乔（Elizabeth Joh）——用特朗普的推文和新闻中发生的各种事情来教我宪法。我们将这个节目命名为《特朗普能教我们什么宪法知识》（What Trump Can Teach Us About Con Law）。
So after Trump left office we decided to keep the show going and I'm so glad we did. There has been so much going on in the Supreme Court that I only understand because of Elizabeth. Of course, we had to change the name. I suggested so many titles. What today can teach us about Conla, what the news can teach us about Conla, Elizabeth rejected all of them, she called them all boring, and the only one that she liked was Swan Real suggestion. What Roman Mars can learn about Khan Law?
特朗普卸任后，我们决定继续做这个节目，我很高兴我们这么做了。最高法院发生了太多事情，多亏了伊丽莎白，我才能理解这些。当然，我们不得不改名。我建议了好多标题，比如《今天能教我们什么宪法知识》、《新闻能教我们什么宪法知识》，但伊丽莎白都拒绝了，她说这些都很无聊。她唯一喜欢的是斯旺（Swan）的建议：《罗曼·马尔斯能从宪法中学到什么？》（What Roman Mars Can Learn About Con Law）。
Since Elizabeth is the brains of the operation, that's the one we went with. Sorry we're all against the staff of Nine Empire, I take a couple weeks off so that we can adjust our schedules to fit in vacations, and rather than a repeat or nothing, I want it to present to you the latest episode of what Roman Mars can learn about Khan Law. I love 9.9 PI and it'll always be the most important job I have. But talking to Elizabeth and sharing her brilliant analysis with the world is the kind of public service entertaining journalism that got me into this business in the first place.
既然伊丽莎白是这个节目的智囊，我们就用了这个名字。抱歉，我们都在忙《99%无形》的工作，我休了几周假，以便调整日程来安排假期。与其重播旧节目或什么都不发，我想为大家呈现《罗曼·马尔斯能从宪法中学到什么》的最新一集。我热爱《99%无形》，它永远是我最重要的工作。但与伊丽莎白交谈并与世界分享她精彩的分析，正是那种让我最初投身这一行业的公共服务型娱乐新闻。
It is so vital to me and critical to the world. So I hope you listen and subscribe and enjoy. So we are talking on Tuesday to lie 26 at about 1215 pm. And what is our subject for this episode? Well, let's talk about the longest week of a Supreme Court term ever. Yeah, I felt it. I felt it too. In any Supreme Court term, which begins every October, the Supreme Court tends to issue its most important decisions at the end of the term, which is usually at the end of June, and this term wasn't any exception.
这对我来说至关重要，对世界也至关重要。所以我希望你们收听、订阅并享受它。我们是在7月26日周二下午12点15分左右录制的。这一集的主题是什么呢？好吧，我们来聊聊最高法院有史以来最漫长的一周。是的，我感觉到了，我也深有同感。在每年10月开始的最高法院任期中，最高法院往往会在任期结束时（通常是6月底）发布最重要的裁决，这一任期也不例外。
But it was a different kind of term. The Supreme Court decided to unrecognize a constitutional right. That's what happened when the conservative majority on the court overturned Roe v. Wade in the case of Dobbs versus Jackson women's health organization. So now states can criminalize abortion entirely and some states have started to do just that. That was June 24th. The Supreme Court also decided to expand another constitutional right. In New York State, Rifle, and Pistol Association versus Bruin,
但这是一种不同寻常的任期。最高法院决定不再承认一项宪法权利。这就是法院的保守派多数在“多布斯诉杰克逊妇女健康组织案”（Dobbs v. Jackson Women's Health Organization）中推翻“罗诉韦德案”（Roe v. Wade）时发生的事情。所以现在各州可以完全将堕胎定为刑事犯罪，一些州已经开始这么做了。那是6月24日。最高法院还决定扩大另一项宪法权利。在“纽约州步枪与手枪协会诉布鲁恩案”（New York State Rifle and Pistol Association v. Bruen）中，
the court decided that the Second Amendment protects a broad right to carry guns outside of your home. In this Second Amendment case, just like in the abortion rights case, the court said what matters is history and tradition, but just in the other way. Now, if the states want to impose rules on carrying guns in public after Bruin, they have to show that the regulation is consistent with this nation's historical tradition of firearms regulation. That was June 23. But that last week wasn't about just guns and abortion. The last week of this
法院裁定，第二修正案保护在住所外携带枪支的广泛权利。在这个第二修正案案件中，就像在堕胎权案件中一样，法院表示重要的是历史和传统，只是方式不同。现在，如果各州想在布鲁恩案后对在公共场合携带枪支施加规则，他们必须证明该法规符合这个国家的枪支监管历史传统。那是6月23日。但最后那周不仅仅是关于枪支和堕胎。今年最高法院任期的最后一周，
Supreme Court term this year is probably the most historically significant one, maybe in almost a hundred years. The Chief Justice said that overturning row was a jolt to the legal system. That's only partially right. The six-person conservative majority on the court has made it clear that they are intent on changing constitutional law, that they are in a hurry, and that they are just getting started. So what happened in those other cases and why are they so important? Time to find out. Let's do it. O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O-O This is what Roman Mars can learn about Khan Law, an ongoing series of indeterminate length where we take the disiently inconsistent decisions of the Supreme Court and use them to examine our constitution like we never have before.
可能是近百年来历史上意义最重大的一周。首席大法官说，推翻“罗诉韦德案”是对法律体系的冲击。这只说对了一部分。法院中六名保守派多数成员已经明确表示，他们意图改变宪法，他们很匆忙，而且他们才刚刚开始。那么其他案件中发生了什么，为什么它们如此重要？是时候找出答案了。让我们开始吧。（此处省略重复的语气词）这就是《罗曼·马尔斯能从宪法中学到什么》，这是一个长度不定的持续系列节目，我们利用最高法院那些截然不同的裁决，以前所未有的方式审视我们的宪法。
Our music is from Doomfree Records, our professor at Neighbor Is Elizabeth Jo, and I'm your fellow student and host, Roman Mars. So let's start with religion. The first amendment both protects the free exercise of religion, that's called the Free Exercise Clause, and bars the government from establishing government-sponsored religion. That's called the establishment clause. Now both of these are in the actual text of the First Amendment, but what they mean and how those two clauses relate to one another is not obvious. So of course it's been up to the Supreme Court to interpret these questions. Now, I'm sure you've heard of the term separation of church and state that we don't have an official
我们的音乐来自Doomtree唱片公司，我们的教授兼邻居是伊丽莎白·乔，我是你们的同学兼主持人罗曼·马尔斯。那么，让我们从宗教开始。第一修正案既保护宗教自由行使（这被称为“自由行使条款”），也禁止政府建立政府支持的宗教（这被称为“设立条款”）。现在，这两者都在第一修正案的实际文本中，但它们的含义以及这两个条款如何相互关联并不明显。所以，当然，解释这些问题就成了最高法院的职责。现在，我相信你们听说过“政教分离”这个词，即我们没有官方的
government religion, but that this is a distinction that the court has not always been entirely clear about. And there are most recent cases show the direction they're going in. On June 21st, the court had decided a case called Carson versus Macon. That involved a challenge to the way Maine handled its education funding. Maine has rural areas where there aren't any public schools, so you need to do something for those students. And the state of Maine addressed the problem in this way. A public school district
政府宗教，但法院并不总是完全清楚这种区别。我们最近的案例显示了他们正在前进的方向。6月21日，法院裁决了一个名为“卡森诉梅肯案”（Carson v. Makin）的案件。这涉及对缅因州处理教育资金方式的质疑。缅因州有农村地区，那里没有公立学校，所以你需要为这些学生做点什么。缅因州是这样解决这个问题的：公立学区
can decide to pay the tuition at a local private school so long as it is not a religious one. And you can see the logic here, right? If they did, wouldn't that be official sponsorship of a religion? And the state didn't want to do that. But in the Carson case, the six conservatives decided that the state's ban on religious schools discriminated against religion. In other words, Maine's attempt to avoid the establishment clause is bar, violated the free exercise clause. So according to the six-person majority,
可以决定支付当地私立学校的学费，只要它不是宗教学校。你们能看出这里的逻辑，对吧？如果他们支付了，那不就是对宗教的官方资助吗？州政府不想那样做。但在卡森案中，六名保守派法官裁定，州政府对宗教学校的禁令歧视了宗教。换句话说，缅因州为避免违反“设立条款”所做的努力，违反了“自由行使条款”。所以根据六人多数派的意见，
the conservative justices, Maine's program was unconstitutional. But to give you an even better example of how far the conservatives are going when it comes to religion is another case decided on also that last week of the term. It's called Kennedy versus Bremerton School District, and this is a case about prayer and public schools. A good way to think about this case is by breaking it up into three questions, I think. First, you know, what kind of dispute is this? Is it a workplace case or a private speech case? The second question is, what part of the First Amendment really matters here?
保守派大法官认为，缅因州的计划是违宪的。但为了给你们一个更好的例子，说明保守派在宗教问题上走得有多远，让我们看看在任期最后一周裁决的另一个案件。它被称为“肯尼迪诉布雷默顿学区案”（Kennedy v. Bremerton School District），这是一个关于公立学校祈祷的案件。我认为，思考这个案件的一个好方法是将其拆解为三个问题。首先，这是一种什么样的纠纷？是职场案件还是私人言论案件？第二个问题是，第一修正案的哪一部分在这里真正重要？
And then the third question, believe it or not, is what actually happened? Okay, so let's start out with what the majority says. Joseph Kennedy is hired in 2008 as an assistant coach for the football team at Bremerton High School. So that's a public high school in Washington State. That's why we're talking about the first amendment. Kennedy, let's call on the coach, has started to make it his practice to pray at the 50 yard line of the football field. That's the very middle of the football field. as soon as the games are over. So he starts this midfield prayer, as soon as he's hired, and over time it becomes a practice where most of the student players join him in this on the field prayer, as soon as the game is over.
然后第三个问题，信不信由你，到底发生了什么？好吧，让我们从多数派的说法开始。约瑟夫·肯尼迪（Joseph Kennedy）于2008年被聘为布雷默顿高中橄榄球队的助理教练。这是一所位于华盛顿州的公立高中。这就是为什么我们在谈论第一修正案。肯尼迪，我们称他为教练，开始养成在橄榄球场50码线上祈祷的习惯。那是橄榄球场的最中间。比赛一结束他就开始。所以他一被聘用就开始这种中场祈祷，随着时间的推移，这变成了一种习惯，大多数学生球员在比赛结束后都会加入他的球场祈祷。
And then the coach also starts to deliver religious speeches after the game, too. Was this okay under his workplace rules? No. The school district had a specific policy. They said that school staff shall neither encourage or discourage a student from engaging in oral or silent prayer or any other form of devotional activity. Not only that, the school district said that religious services shall not be conducted in connection with any school sponsored or school related activity. But for whatever reason, the school district doesn't find out that the coach is doing this until another school's football coach tells the Bremerton principal that,
然后教练在比赛结束后也开始发表宗教演讲。这在他的工作规则下是可以的吗？不。学区有一项具体政策。他们规定，学校员工不得鼓励或劝阻学生进行口头或默祷，或任何其他形式的虔诚活动。不仅如此，学区还规定，不得在与任何学校赞助或学校相关活动有关的情况下进行宗教仪式。但无论出于什么原因，学区直到另一所学校的橄榄球教练告诉布雷默顿校长之前，都不知道教练在做这件事，
hey, it's cool that you allow a coach to do this, pray on the field. And this happens years later. The school district tells the coach, look, you have to stop doing this. You can't keep praying in the middle of the football field with our students as the coach right after the football game ends, okay?
嘿，你们允许教练在球场上祈祷真是太酷了。这发生在几年后。学区告诉教练，听着，你必须停止这样做。你不能在橄榄球比赛结束后，作为教练继续在球场中间和我们的学生一起祈祷，好吗？
You're making it look like the school is endorsing religion, and not only that, a particular religion. We're not allowed to do that. We'd be violating the Constitution, and the coach initially stops. But then he gets a lawyer. And the coach's lawyer tells the district, you're violating my client's right to exercise his first amendment rights. He's going to go back to the 50-yard line prayers at the next game, and this is October 16th, 2015. He does, he goes back, he does it, and he repeats this for two more games.
你让学校看起来像是在支持宗教，而且不仅如此，还是支持特定的宗教。我们不允许这样做。我们会违反宪法。教练最初停止了。但他找了一位律师。教练的律师告诉学区，你们正在侵犯我客户行使第一修正案权利的权利。他将在下一场比赛中回到50码线祈祷，那是2015年10月16日。他确实这么做了，他回去了，他做了，并且在接下来的两场比赛中重复了这一点。
What does the district do? They fire him. The coach sues, and the case goes up to the Supreme Court, and the conservative majority decides in a six-three decision, and the court's opinion is written by Justice Courage. So, I want to go back to those three questions to help you understand what's going on in the case, right? So, the first one was, is this a workplace issue or a private speech issue?
学区做了什么？他们解雇了他。教练起诉，案件上诉到最高法院，保守派多数以六比三的裁决做出决定，法院的意见由戈萨奇（Gorsuch）大法官撰写。所以，我想回到那三个问题来帮助你们理解这个案件中发生了什么，对吧？所以，第一个是，这是职场问题还是私人言论问题？
If the coach was speaking as a government employee, a government, and that's the school district, could restrict the speech of its own employees when it comes to things that they're doing as part of their duties. And it's the same reason, and you and I've talked about this before, that school districts have a pretty good argument that they can tell their teachers
如果教练是以政府雇员的身份发言，而政府（即学区）可以在涉及员工职责范围内的事情上限制其员工的言论。这就是同样的原因，我和你们之前谈过，学区有很好的理由告诉他们的老师，
that teaching some subjects, like critical race theory, is not allowed, the same idea that the government can restrict the speech of its employees when it comes to their duties. But if the coach's prayers were private speech, then the district would have a harder, but not impossible time of trying to restrict what the coach was doing. So the conservative majority in the coach's case says, this is clearly private speech. He wasn't coaching, he was engaged in quiet prayer. And if we let the school district fire this coach for his quiet Christian prayer, then you know, what else could happen? The school district could also fire a Muslim teacher for wearing a headscarf
教授某些科目（如批判性种族理论）是不被允许的，同样的道理，政府可以在涉及职责时限制其员工的言论。但如果教练的祈祷是私人言论，那么学区想要限制教练的行为就会更困难，但并非不可能。所以教练案中的保守派多数派说，这显然是私人言论。他当时没有在执教，他是在进行安静的祈祷。如果我们允许学区因为他的安静基督教祈祷而解雇这位教练，那么你们知道，还会发生什么？学区也可以解雇一名戴头巾的穆斯林老师，
in the classroom. So that's how they want to see it. Then there's the next question. Which part of the Constitution is important here? Remember, the school had a policy of telling all of its employees don't do anything as a part of your job on school grounds or as a part of a school function that makes it look like you're encouraging a particular religious practice. Why? Because of the establishment clause, right? You're not supposed to do that. But the majority that decides in favor of the establishment clause, right? You're not supposed to do that.
在课堂上。所以他们想这样看。然后是下一个问题。宪法的哪一部分在这里很重要？记住，学校有一项政策，告诉所有员工，不要在学校场地或作为学校职能的一部分做任何让你看起来像是在鼓励特定宗教习俗的事情。为什么？因为“设立条款”，对吧？你不应该那样做。但是支持教练的多数派，
But the majority that decides in favor of the coach doesn't focus on the establishment clause at all. For the conservative majority, this case is about religious freedom and religious freedom only. Justice Gorsuch says that this is a case about religious tolerance. So what happened to the coach was that his government employer punished him for engaging in what Gorsuch says is a brief, quiet, personal, religious observance.
根本没有关注“设立条款”。对于保守派多数派来说，这个案件是关于宗教自由，而且仅仅是关于宗教自由。戈萨奇大法官说，这是一个关于宗教宽容的案件。所以教练身上发生的事情是，他的政府雇主因为他从事戈萨奇所说的简短、安静、个人的宗教仪式而惩罚了他。
And in other words, he's saying that the government punished the coach and violated his first amendment rights. All right, and that leads us to the third question in this case, what actually happened? The coach argued from the beginning that he had the right to engage in what he called brief quiet prayer on the football field right after the game had concluded.
换句话说，他是在说政府惩罚了教练并侵犯了他的第一修正案权利。好吧，这把我们带到了这个案件的第三个问题，到底发生了什么？教练从一开始就辩称，他有权在比赛结束后立即在橄榄球场上进行他所说的简短、安静的祈祷。
Now what's interesting here is that Justice Gorsuch picks up this phrase and puts it in the majority's conclusion, that this coach has a right to brief, quiet, personal, religious observance. So I was curious about this, so I took another look at the opinion. Gorsuch refers to the coach's prayers as quiet 12 times. He really, really thinks this is about a quiet prayer. And so how can you punish that, right? How can you punish a guy who's just quietly praying? But then just as Sotomayor pens her descent, she says, wait a minute. Do you think this is about punishing a guy
现在有趣的是，戈萨奇大法官采纳了这个短语并将其放入了多数派的结论中，即这位教练有权进行简短、安静、个人的宗教仪式。所以我对此很好奇，所以我又看了一遍意见书。戈萨奇12次提到教练的祈祷是“安静的”。他真的、真的认为这是关于安静的祈祷。所以你怎么能惩罚那个，对吧？你怎么能惩罚一个只是在安静祈祷的人？但随后索托马约尔（Sotomayor）大法官写下了她的异议，她说，等一下。你们认为这是关于惩罚一个
who just wants to quietly pray on his own? She says, why don't we take a look at the record? So remember the beginning, you know, he's praying with the students at these football games. And remember that the school district launched an investigation into the coaches practices. Well, the athletic director initially told the coach, stop doing this, stop praying with the players at the games.
只想安静祈祷的人吗？她说，我们为什么不看看记录呢？所以记住开始的时候，你知道，他在这些橄榄球比赛中和学生一起祈祷。并且记住学区对教练的行为展开了调查。好吧，体育主管最初告诉教练，停止这样做，停止在比赛中和球员一起祈祷。
And then the coach's response was, he goes on Facebook and he says, I think I might have been fired for praying. He hadn't been. But that's what he says. He makes his public announcement. And keep in mind that he was told to stop. He says he's going to continue, right, after he gets into this dispute with his employer. He didn't just decide this on his own.
然后教练的回应是，他上了Facebook，他说，我想我可能因为祈祷而被解雇了。他当时并没有被解雇。但这就是他说的。他发表了他的公开声明。并且记住他被告知要停止。他说他要继续，对吧，在他与雇主发生争执之后。他不是自己决定这么做的。
He went on a media campaign announcing his plans to pray at the October 16th, 2015 homecoming game. The Seattle Times headline that covered the story said, Bremerton football coach vows to pray after game despite order. And when the homecoming game ends, the coach did, of course, in fact, kneel in prayer, just like Gorsuch said, but Gorsuch admitted what else happened. The coach was joined by other coaches and players. He's surrounded by TV cameras.
他发起了一场媒体运动，宣布他计划在2015年10月16日的返校节比赛中祈祷。《西雅图时报》报道这个故事的标题说，布雷默顿橄榄球教练誓言尽管有命令，仍要在赛后祈祷。当返校节比赛结束时，教练确实，当然，实际上跪下祈祷了，就像戈萨奇说的那样，但戈萨奇承认还发生了什么。教练加入了其他教练和球员。他被电视摄像机包围了。
The public rushes the field. They knocked down the student band members. There was a group of satanists who announced that they were going to come and join the prayer on the field, but they weren't allowed to go on the field actually. They were barred from doing so unlike the coach. This is an exactly the picture of quiet prayer that Gorsuch painted in order to justify ruling in the coach's favor. And there's more here too that six conservatives said that this was primarily a case about religious freedom. Well, is that really right? The school district clearly wrote their own policies to avoid
公众冲进球场。他们撞倒了学生乐队成员。有一群撒旦教徒宣布他们要来加入球场上的祈祷，但他们实际上不被允许进入球场。他们被禁止这样做，不像教练。这完全不是戈萨奇为了证明支持教练的裁决而描绘的安静祈祷的画面。这里还有更多内容，六名保守派说这主要是一个关于宗教自由的案件。好吧，那真的对吗？学区显然写了自己的政策来避免
establishment clause problems. They didn't want to endorse any particular religion. Another way to think about the establishment clause is to say that, well, it demands that the government be neutral about religion. And when you have a school employee leading a prayer at a school event on school grounds, wearing his school uniform, well, you could also say this is a form of coercion, right? Coercing kids to pray. Now, of course, the coach never told his student
“设立条款”的问题。他们不想支持任何特定的宗教。思考“设立条款”的另一种方式是说，好吧，它要求政府在宗教问题上保持中立。当你有学校员工在学校活动中、在学校场地上、穿着校服带领祈祷时，好吧，你也可以说这是一种胁迫，对吧？强迫孩子们祈祷。现在，当然，教练从未告诉他的学生
athletes to pray. But as Justice Sonomayor pointed out in her descent, you don't need to say very much when you're an authority figure for kids. And in fact, after the dispute between the coach and the school district began, several parents told the district that their own kids had prayed with the coach just so they wouldn't stick out. They didn't want to be excluded. And then after the coach was eventually disciplined and his contract wasn't renewed, no players prayed on the field at all.
运动员去祈祷。但正如索托马约尔大法官在她的异议中所指出的，当你是一个孩子的权威人物时，你不需要说太多。事实上，在教练和学区之间的纠纷开始后，几位家长告诉学区，他们自己的孩子和教练一起祈祷只是为了不显得格格不入。他们不想被排斥。然后，在教练最终受到纪律处分且合同未续签后，根本没有球员在球场上祈祷。
So what you have here is a case where there is certainly a clash between the establishment clause and the free exercise clause. There isn't an easy way to resolve that tension, but in the Bremerton case, the six-person majority made it very, very clear where they're in Tristly. They are not interested in the establishment clause. They see this purely in terms of religious freedom. But in order to get to that conclusion, they really had to ignore a lot of what actually happened on those three games. It's amazing.
所以你们这里有一个案件，其中“设立条款”和“自由行使条款”之间确实存在冲突。没有简单的方法来解决这种紧张关系，但在布雷默顿案中，六人多数派非常、非常清楚他们的立场。他们对“设立条款”不感兴趣。他们纯粹从宗教自由的角度来看待这个问题。但为了得出这个结论，他们真的不得不忽略很多在三场比赛中实际发生的事情。这太令人震惊了。
And it's a recall, like, sort of my order, put in a picture of all the people praying on the, like, to show that it wasn't why it prayer, that it was really like a gathering of people, I've never seen a picture inside of an opinion before. Yeah, that's right. They're not too common, but she posted a picture that comes from the Appeals Court decision from the Ninth Circuit. And in that picture, you see the homecoming game.
而且这让人想起，索托马约尔放了一张所有人在祈祷的照片，为了表明那不是安静的祈祷，它实际上更像是一群人的聚集，我以前从未在意见书中见过照片。是的，没错。它们不太常见，但她贴出了一张来自第九巡回上诉法院裁决的照片。在那张照片中，你可以看到返校节比赛。
And remember, Gorsuch had said, this guy is really doing his own private religious thing, and I can't believe the school district punished him for it. But in the picture itself, you see the coach praying. He's surrounded by at least 20 student athletes and a bunch of television cameras. I mean, in a way, you could say that by defying what the school district had told him, he was saying, look, I have the right to engage in school-sponsored demonstrative religious practices. So, a lot depends on what facts you decide to see and how you decide to characterize them.
并且记住，戈萨奇曾说，这家伙真的在做他自己的私人宗教活动，我不敢相信学区因此惩罚了他。但在照片本身中，你可以看到教练在祈祷。他被至少20名学生运动员和一堆电视摄像机包围着。我的意思是，在某种程度上，你可以说通过违抗学区告诉他的话，他是在说，看，我有权从事学校赞助的示范性宗教活动。所以，很多取决于你决定看到什么事实以及你决定如何描述它们。
Yeah, yeah, fast name. And you know, this is just the beginning, of course. I think this is not the last of what we're going to see in terms of what the court is thinking in terms of the clash between religious freedom rights and the establishment clause. And as sort of my or put it in her descent, the court sets us further down a perilous path enforcing states to entangle themselves with religion, with all of our rights hanging in the balance.
是的，是的，太迷人了。而且你知道，这当然只是开始。我认为这不会是我们看到的关于法院在宗教自由权利和“设立条款”之间冲突的想法的最后一次。正如索托马约尔在她的异议中所说，法院让我们在一条危险的道路上走得更远，强迫各州将自己与宗教纠缠在一起，而我们所有的权利都悬而未决。
Because of course, now a school district like Bremer 10 has to be forced to allow this to happen. They can't do anything about it. Yeah. That was June 27th. And then the six-person majority had another target that week. Climate change.
因为当然，现在像布雷默顿这样的学区必须被迫允许这种情况发生。他们对此无能为力。是的。那是6月27日。然后六人多数派在那周还有另一个目标。气候变化。
Oh goodness, okay. Let's talk about that. In 2015, the Obama administration adopted what they called the Clean Power Plan. So this was a set of rules designed to address climate change. Huge problem needs a big plan, right? So part of what was going on in this plan is that power plans were supposed to reduce their emissions by doing things like shifting more of their own production to resources like wind and solar.
哦天哪，好吧。让我们谈谈那个。2015年，奥巴马政府通过了他们所谓的“清洁电力计划”。所以这是一套旨在解决气候变化的规则。巨大的问题需要一个大的计划，对吧？所以这个计划中发生的一部分是，发电厂应该通过做一些事情来减少排放，比如将他们自己的生产更多地转向风能和太阳能等资源。
So as a policy matter, that kind of makes sense right. Maybe if you want to have less greenhouse gas emissions that's what you do. But the plan was challenged in court like these plans often are so as put on hold didn't go into effect. Then in 2019 the Trump administration said we have another plan. You can probably guess how different the Trump administration's plans were. But that plan was also put on hold after it had its own legal challenges. And then the Biden administration asked the federal appeals court not to reinstate the Trump rules after this court challenge, because look, now there's a new administration, we're going to have new regulations. Despite all of this, the Supreme Court decided to review the case.
所以作为政策问题，这在某种程度上是有道理的，对吧。也许如果你想减少温室气体排放，那就是你所做的。但该计划在法庭上受到了挑战，就像这些计划经常受到的那样，所以被搁置了，没有生效。然后在2019年，特朗普政府说我们有另一个计划。你们可能猜到特朗普政府的计划有多么不同。但该计划在经历了自己的法律挑战后也被搁置了。然后拜登政府要求联邦上诉法院在这次法庭挑战后不要恢复特朗普的规则，因为看，现在有了新政府，我们将有新的法规。尽管如此，最高法院还是决定复审该案。
So both the Obama and Trump era plans about carbon emissions were rules issued by the EPA, the Environmental Protection Agency. And this is an administrative agency that is created by Congress and receives its powers from Congress. The narrow question in this case is whether a specific provision of the Clean Air Act gives the EPA the power to do things like require power plants to switch some of their production to renewable sources like solar and wind. That's pretty dry and boring, doesn't get anybody very excited, right? And if you have a challenge to how an agency uses its
所以奥巴马和特朗普时代的关于碳排放的计划都是由环保署（EPA）发布的规则。这是一个由国会创建并从国会获得权力的行政机构。这个案件中的狭窄问题是，《清洁空气法》的一项具体条款是否赋予了环保署权力去做一些事情，比如要求发电厂将其部分生产转向太阳能和风能等可再生能源。这相当枯燥乏味，不会让任何人感到兴奋，对吧？如果你对一个机构如何使用其
statutory power, that's the power given by Congress, you focus primarily on the text of that law, right? That makes sense. Well, in West Virginia versus EPA, the sixth Justice Majority announces a new legal test. They make it up. It's called the major questions doctrine. What does that mean? Well, according to the majority, this doctrine means that when an administrative agency like the EPA uses its power to make decisions that the court calls a vast economic and political significance,
法定权力（即国会赋予的权力）提出质疑，你主要关注该法律的文本，对吧？这有道理。好吧，在“西弗吉尼亚州诉环保署案”中，六名大法官多数派宣布了一项新的法律测试。他们编造出来的。它被称为“重大问题原则”（major questions doctrine）。那是什么意思？好吧，根据多数派的说法，这一原则意味着当像环保署这样的行政机构使用其权力做出法院称之为具有巨大经济和政治意义的决定时，
that court shouldn't assume that Congress meant to give them this power. And in fact, if Congress wants to give them this huge power, they have to be clear about it. They have to say, this is exactly what we intended. With this brand new rule, the six-person majority decides, well, there is no way that the EPA can rely on a not very often used provision of the Clean Air Act to make this enormous change in the way that we regulate power plants, even if it's to address climate change. But this isn't a case that's just about a single environmental law. The court refers to two of its prior decisions to decide this case.
法院不应假设国会打算赋予他们这种权力。事实上，如果国会想赋予他们这种巨大的权力，他们必须明确说明。他们必须说，这正是我们打算做的。有了这个全新的规则，六人多数派决定，好吧，环保署绝不可能依赖《清洁空气法》中一项不常使用的条款来对我们监管发电厂的方式做出这种巨大的改变，即使是为了解决气候变化。但这不仅仅是一个关于单一环境法的案件。法院引用了其之前的两项裁决来决定这个案件。
What is it rely on? It's rejection of the CDC's eviction moratorium as a COVID-19 response in 2021, and it's rejection of the OSHA employee vaccine mandate in 2022. The EPA using its authority to combat climate change, the court says this is no different. So one way to think about this is yes, this is really about the Clean Air Act and it has a lot of importance for environmental law, but West Virginia versus EPA is also an all-out attack on the ability of administrative agencies, including the EPA, to address the major issues that are facing the country, including climate change.
它依赖什么？它在2021年拒绝了疾控中心（CDC）作为新冠疫情应对措施的驱逐暂停令，以及它在2022年拒绝了职业安全与健康管理局（OSHA）的员工疫苗强制令。法院说，环保署利用其权力应对气候变化与此没有什么不同。所以思考这个问题的一种方式是，是的，这确实是关于《清洁空气法》，它对环境法有很大的重要性，但“西弗吉尼亚州诉环保署案”也是对行政机构（包括环保署）解决国家面临的重大问题（包括气候变化）的能力的全面攻击。
And Justice Kagan here writes a blistering descent. She's joined by the other two liberal justices. It's pretty acid. The majority solution, she says, well, Congress has to be very specific in telling agencies what to do. Kagan points out that's pretty silly. She says, members of Congress often don't know enough
卡根（Kagan）大法官在这里写了一份尖锐的异议。她得到了其他两名自由派大法官的支持。这相当尖刻。她说，多数派的解决方案是，国会必须非常具体地告诉机构该做什么。卡根指出这很愚蠢。她说，国会议员往往不知道足够多，
and know they don't know enough to regulate sensibly on an issue, and that's why we have these agencies in the first place. The larger consequence here is that the EPA decision is a big win for conservatives who want to take down the administrative state, the whole set of agencies that exist, you know, the ones that regulate our air, our food, our drugs, our workplaces, our financial marketplaces. And how did they do that? Because the Supreme Court in its six-person majority
并且知道他们不知道足够多来理智地监管一个问题，这就是为什么我们首先有这些机构的原因。这里更大的后果是，环保署的决定对于那些想要推翻行政国家（即现有的整套机构，你知道，那些监管我们的空气、食物、药品、工作场所、金融市场的机构）的保守派来说是一个巨大的胜利。他们是怎么做到的？因为最高法院在其六人多数派中
invented a new rule for topics that it doesn't like. And Kagan, in her dissent, summed it up this way. Whatever else this court may know about, it does not have a clue about how to address climate change. The court appoints itself instead of Congress or the expert agency, the decision maker on climate policy. I cannot think of many more things that are frightening. That was June 30, 2022.
为它不喜欢的议题发明了一项新规则。卡根在她的异议中这样总结道：无论这个法院还知道什么，它对如何解决气候变化一无所知。法院任命自己而不是国会或专家机构作为气候政策的决策者。我想不出还有什么比这更可怕的事情了。那是2022年6月30日。
The last day of the last week of the most important Supreme Court term in decades. Oh my God. Oh, there was so much worse than I imagined. So when you look at all these decisions in their totality, what does that mean to you? Well, you know, each of these cases is sort of alarming on their own, I think.
几十年来最重要的最高法院任期的最后一周的最后一天。哦我的上帝。哦，这比我想象的要糟糕得多。所以当你全面审视所有这些裁决时，这对你意味着什么？好吧，你知道，我认为这些案件中的每一个单独来看都有些令人担忧。
But what we see now, I think, is the most political court in many, many decades. It's driven by a group of justices with the exception of Thomas, who were appointed by presidents who lost the popular vote. And just in one week, the justices decided cases that as a policy matter are out of step with what majorities
但我认为我们现在看到的是几十年来最政治化的法院。它由一群大法官驱动，除了托马斯（Thomas）之外，他们都是由在普选中失败的总统任命的。仅仅在一周内，大法官们就决定了一些案件，作为政策问题，这些案件与大多数
of Americans say they think about reproductive rights, gun regulations, and climate change. And so you might counter by saying, well, what about conservative judicial values, right? Maybe that's what's binding all this together. But let's think about the usual justifications for why conservative judges rule the way they do. Well, it turns out that if you look at that last week of the court, what you see is incrementalism when they feel
美国人对生殖权利、枪支法规和气候变化的看法不一致。所以你可能会反驳说，那保守派司法价值观呢，对吧？也许这就是把这一切结合在一起的东西。但让我们想想保守派法官为什么会这样裁决的通常理由。好吧，事实证明，如果你看看法院的最后一周，你看到的是当他们觉得
like it, sticking to prior decisions or starry decisions when they feel like it, sticking to the text, when they feel like it, states rights, when they feel like it, and individual rights when they feel like it. So it's pretty clear that after that last week of June that this is just the beginning of their project. Yeah, I mean, that's really fun. So, punished is about it all. It's like, I heard David Plott's talking about this
可以时就采取渐进主义，当他们觉得可以时就坚持先例，当他们觉得可以时就坚持文本，当他们觉得可以时就坚持州权，当他们觉得可以时就坚持个人权利。所以很明显，在6月的最后一周之后，这只是他们计划的开始。是的，我的意思是，这真的很有趣。所以，惩罚是一切。就像，我听到大卫·普洛特（David Plotz）在谈论这个
on the slate political gamfas. Bad law is bad law, but uncertainty has a real corroding effect on how we live. And if, in some cases, individual rights are paramount, in some cases, they're thrown away, and it's all very capricious, it really makes for just uneasiness and uncertainty among the populace. Yeah, I think that's right. And if you look at what's happened just in the month
在Slate的政治播客上。糟糕的法律就是糟糕的法律，但不确定性对我们的生活方式有真正的腐蚀作用。如果，在某些情况下，个人权利是至高无上的，在某些情况下，它们被抛弃了，而且这一切都非常反复无常，它确实在民众中造成了不安和不确定性。是的，我认为那是对的。如果你看看仅仅在
since the court decided, dobs, that's the abortion decision. I mean, one of the biggest ironies is that the conservative majority in DOBS said, well, Roe was bad because the court stepped in to the issue of abortion when it shouldn't have. And in their words, it inflamed the issue of abortion and caused division around the country. And so the implication is that by overturning row, the court is somehow returning stability to the country by getting out of the business of recognizing a constitutional right here.
法院做出“多布斯案”（即堕胎裁决）以来的一个月里发生了什么。我的意思是，最大的讽刺之一是“多布斯案”中的保守派多数派说，好吧，“罗诉韦德案”很糟糕，因为法院在不应该介入的时候介入了堕胎问题。用他们的话说，它激化了堕胎问题，并在全国范围内造成了分裂。所以暗示是，通过推翻“罗诉韦德案”，法院通过不再承认这里的宪法权利，以某种方式将稳定带回了国家。
But in the month since DOBS, as you point out, I think the opposite has been true, right? That DOBS has created its own kind of chaos. So remember after DOBS, your abortion can now be completely banned by the states. But if you consider that statement, what exactly does that mean? Let's say that a state says that providing an abortion is a crime, except in cases where it's necessary to save a woman's life, or they might use the word medical emergency. Now, a lot of these laws, both very old laws
但在“多布斯案”以来的一个月里，正如你指出的，我认为事实恰恰相反，对吧？“多布斯案”创造了它自己的一种混乱。所以记住在“多布斯案”之后，你的堕胎现在可以被各州完全禁止。但如果你考虑那个声明，那到底意味着什么？假设一个州说提供堕胎是一种犯罪，除非在挽救妇女生命的情况下，或者他们可能会使用“医疗紧急情况”这个词。现在，很多这些法律，既有非常古老的法律，
and the so-called trigger laws that were passed in advance of thinking that Roe was going to be overturned, they were drafted as kind of, you know, making political gains. They weren't really carefully thought out laws. And we're now seeing the consequences of that, because these laws clearly were intended to cover sort of conventional abortions, right? But if you just have a generic law that says, well, you can't have abortions except to save a woman's life,
也有在认为“罗诉韦德案”将被推翻之前提前通过的所谓“触发法”，它们被起草时有点像，你知道，为了获得政治利益。它们并不是真正经过仔细考虑的法律。我们现在正在看到后果，因为这些法律显然旨在涵盖某种传统的堕胎，对吧？但如果你只是有一项通用的法律说，好吧，你不能堕胎，除非为了挽救妇女的生命，
well, what if a pregnant woman is suddenly having a complication where the fetus can't be saved anywhere, right? Where a live birth is no longer possible. Does the doctor have to wait until the woman's about to die to provide the abortion? In other words, watch the suffering of the patient until they feel that they're legally allowed to perform the abortion. And then again, with these hastily or not well-thought-out laws, what counts as an abortion?
好吧，如果一个孕妇突然出现并发症，胎儿在任何地方都无法挽救呢？活产不再可能呢？医生必须等到妇女快要死的时候才能提供堕胎吗？换句话说，看着病人的痛苦，直到他们觉得自己在法律上被允许进行堕胎。然后，再次，对于这些仓促或没有经过深思熟虑的法律，什么算作堕胎？
If a woman has a miscarriage where the fetus is no longer alive, but it's still in her body, it turns out that the procedure used to manage that miscarriage is exactly the same procedure as you'd use for an abortion. So are both of these procedures illegal now? It's also true for drugs, right? If a drug that can be used to end a pregnancy is also one that happens to be routinely prescribed for people with health conditions
如果一个妇女流产了，胎儿不再存活，但它还在她的体内，事实证明，用于处理那种流产的手术与你用于堕胎的手术完全相同。那么这两种手术现在都是非法的吗？对于药物来说也是如此，对吧？如果一种可以用来终止妊娠的药物恰好也是一种经常被开给有健康状况的人的药物，
that have nothing to do with pregnancy, well, will a pharmacist still sell it to you? Right. So again, many of these bands were written to score political points, but it turns out now we're finding out very quickly that they apply to medical procedures and prescriptions that are, it's just not clear whether they're covered by those laws. And it's been left up to hospitals and doctors and pharmacists who understandably don't want to face the possibility of prosecution.
而这些状况与怀孕无关，好吧，药剂师还会卖给你吗？对。所以再次，许多这些禁令是为了得分政治利益而写的，但事实证明，我们现在很快发现它们适用于医疗程序和处方，只是不清楚它们是否在这些法律的涵盖范围内。这留给了医院、医生和药剂师，他们理所当然地不想面临被起诉的可能性。
The result is a lot of suffering. Even for women who never thought that abortion bands would ever apply to them. Well, thank you for this grim roundup of all things that happened in the final week of the last term. Yeah it's definitely not a happy time but it's important to be informed. Well thank you so much for keeping us informed. Thanks Roman. This show is produced by Liz Vichot, Jacob Multinato Medina, Sarah Baker, and me Roman Mars. You can find us online at LearnConLaw.com. All the music and what Roman Mars can learn about Conlaus provided by DoomTree Records,
结果是大量的痛苦。即使对于那些从未想过堕胎禁令会适用于她们的妇女来说也是如此。好吧，谢谢你对上个任期最后一周发生的所有事情的严峻总结。是的，这绝对不是一个快乐的时刻，但了解情况很重要。好吧，非常感谢你让我们了解情况。谢谢罗曼。这个节目由莉兹·维乔特（Liz Vichot）、雅各布·穆尔蒂纳托·梅迪纳（Jacob Multinato Medina）、莎拉·贝克（Sarah Baker）和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。你可以在LearnConLaw.com在线找到我们。所有音乐和《罗曼·马尔斯能从宪法中学到什么》的内容由Doomtree唱片公司提供，
the Midwest Hip Hop Collective. You can find out more about DoomTree Records get merch and learn about their monthly membership exclusives at DoomTree.net. We are a part of the Stitcher and Ser Series XM podcast family. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
中西部嘻哈团体。你可以在Doomtree.net了解更多关于Doomtree唱片公司的信息，购买周边商品，并了解他们的月度会员独家内容。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。